great people don't go through they grow
through the difficulties that come on
their path problems will come issues
will come difficulties will come whoever
you are doesn't matter your own subject
to our own individual worries and
anxieties this the flea was different
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe in you
i believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that i want to see exploder
under the world now I started the mentor
me series to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a few extra
minutes with them some of their mindsets
their beliefs their thought process
seeps into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from one of the best Gabor
Gopal das and how to deal with problems
and difficulties in life mentor me goer
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number 1 see challenges as opportunities
December 10th 1914 there was a massive
explosion in West Orange New Jersey
United States of America ten buildings
in a factory owned by the legendary
inventor Thomas Edison were engulfed by
flames six - gate fire departments
rushed to the scene but could not curb
the chemical fueled inferno after having
dried all that he could as Thomas Edison
calmly stood there watching the fire
destroy his entire life's hard work his
24 year old son Charles came over and
stood next to him in a childlike voice
Edison said to his son Charlie go and
get your mother and her friends they'd
never be able to see a spectacular fire
like this in their entire life
astonished and shocked by spiders
response Charles asked Thomas Edison
our entire Factory is being burnt down
to ashes bed Thomas Edison replied in
complete composure yes
our factory is being burnt down to ashes
but all the mistakes we've made so far
in the factory have also been burnt down
to ashes we will start all over again
tomorrow that evening Thomas Edison told
a New York Times reporter although I'm
67 years old and I'm completely
exhausted from running around and trying
to control the file tomorrow I'll start
all over again
afresh and so he did the next day was a
fresh beginning for Thomas Edison and
his son Charles in trying to rebuild
what had been destroyed by fire often
this is what life does unto us our
dreams are shattered our hopes
broken efforts baffled great people they
don't cry they try to rebuild their
dreams great people don't give up live
up to the challenges that life throws at
them great people don't go through they
grow through the difficulties that come
on their path they start all over again
with great hope with great determination
with great great
and that is why they reach the highest
peaks of success that most people only
aspire for that is why I say no
challenges no success no challenges no
success rule number two smile how many
of you smile
I'd give you a nice one
sorry
oh well my guy when a clear
Maharashtrian stood it he was in school
and teachers teaching English and the
teachers teaching how to count numbers
he wrote numbers on the chalkboard and
on the chalkboard after writing the
numbers he said but who will say this
guy's is 72 Yeti Yeti nigh night and I
said what did I say who's nearly got a
70 to 80 89 99 72 Yeti 89 99
there was a mirage student student
studying in our macular school so the
teacher was teaching numbers and he
wrote on the board numbers and he said
hurry he said 70 82
yet in a Nathan I there was a student in
school Milosh teacher and the teacher
wrote numbers on the and the teacher was
saying breathe so he said seventy Yeti
250 night-night tonight
I'm telling you the same joke again
isn't it do you laugh on the same joke
again no after a while if I tell you
will say couch to go but we don't laugh
on the same joke again why do we cry on
the same problem again you see joke came
to see joke fail Hasini you see problem
pay wrote they read they know
we keep crying on that same issue and
that same problem again and again and
again problems will come issues will
come difficulties will come who ever you
are doesn't matter
chipolina cheetah egg bar jalopy lagoon
cinta nepal jalabiya skills are life
skills are present may cannot experience
fulfillment ladies and gentlemen God has
a plan an amazing plan with all the
challenges with all the difficulties
with all the troubles that he sends our
way he is an incredible plan none of us
know what none of us can see how
neurosis can understand why and
therefore at that point of time all we
do is cry we can't understand why if
only we understood what the plan is even
while going through that crisis we would
probably smile
easily acetone belly rooijen the gimmick
[Music]
his holiness rather not Swami says do
not take this material world so
seriously because it's always changing
something that you take so seriously
today is going to change tomorrow was
cool liquor great omen also smile rule
number three accept problems as a part
of life everyone has their own
individual pressures as students you
have pressures to study people who work
go through pressures of deadlines and
commitments at work
people who are married are worried about
family pressures their mortgages their
bills and their mother-in-law's and
father-in-law's and sister-in-laws and
brother-in-law's and whatever else
exists you know I was telling the story
the other day this is my favourite story
I just keep sharing it all the time
this is what really happened you can't
believe this but this happened i came to
london heathrow once and at London
Heathrow I came to the immigration
officer and this immigration officer
elderly man he said so what are you here
for I said to give talks he said then
are you living in to Woodforde center I
said yeah he said how long will you stay
here for I said about two weeks he said
and can I ask you a personal question
I said please sir he said I'm married I
[Music]
said you were an Indian aren't you I'm a
monk he said no I was just
cross-checking just in case and then he
said can I ask you another one place I
said yes he said are you not missing
anything in life he thought he caught me
at the wrong foot
are you not missing anything in life I
said of things I am he said what I said
problems
you know what who loved my answer
believe me hand on my heart he stamped
my passport and as I'm walking out of
the gate he put his hand on my head
blessing me said son remain like this
son remain like this you will never have
to go through any issues and your
problems in life dad but you know what I
mean it's nice to laugh at but as I
walked through the gate I turned to him
and told him look gentlemen I must tell
you something don't think that me as a
monk is free from problems anyone who
lives in this dog-eat-dog world as they
might say or anyone who lives in this
world full of rat race and pressures
whether it's you who are a student study
or one a few culprits of business people
who's working or Meriden an old lady
who's kind of dealing with family life
or myself is a monk they're all subject
to our own pressures we are all subject
to our own stresses we are all subject
to our own individual worries and
anxieties this to flee was different
rule number four except informed and
transformed choices here we have put in
many many complicated situations I want
to offer all of you a very powerful tool
a very simple one when you are talking
about making a choice weigh the
consequences and just decide which of
the two consequences you are okay to
bear moral dilemmas are easy to solve
because moral dilemmas are between good
and bad ethical dilemmas are hard to
solve because ethical dilemmas are
between bad and bad or good and good
remember this always you will have to
make one choice you're not going to be
spared by life you will always have to
make one choice choices means two things
to remember informed choices and
transform choices
we should make informed choices what is
an informed choices based on proper
knowledge based on proper deliberation
based on proper consideration based on
proper analysis
not half as early whimsically made
choices and what is transformed choices
choice is based on a spiritual strength
so when we have a combination of
informed and transform then we make a
choice because informant we know what to
do but we can't do it and thus we
definitely need to make transform
choices and therefore they say and an
elegant person will open your mind a
handsome person will open your eyes ah
quills asana recognize I mean but a
gentleman will open your heart and what
to speak of an intelligent handsome
gentleman this is what I appeal to all
of you become an intelligent handsome
gentleman and rule number five the last
one before very special bonus clip is
invest in people on the wooden floor
tired from the anxiety last night and
suddenly a second one of my friends came
up to me and woke me up say he's leaving
he's leaving I gotta get rid myself
together rushing to go to the room when
my dear friend Stoker Krishna thus was
leaving his body memories were flashing
from my mind as I was rushing towards
this room he was amongst with me I
stated to be otherwise stayed together
at a certain point he decided to move on
and get Madeline Aventa he'd taken a job
in the hospital we love the philosophy
as the library he just gotten married
his wife was pregnant and while the
wife's pregnant she was diagnosed with
melanoma cancerous he decided that he
wanted to leave the body in the
monastery where he spent most of his
time we got into a monster as this
memories flashed in my mind and I was
rushing there I remembered every day are
interesting God's names to him on the
harmonium my tearful eyes as I cry
seeing a dear friend struck in melanoma
cancer every single time he looked at
him my vision was blurred because
someone Saudi yet this gentleman was
amazing he had a beaming face all the
excruciating pain that he went through
haven't affected as determined resolved
you look at space look at that smile
no Martin was working on them unless
this stuff works his wife I didn't but -
baby girl they brought the baby girl -
right next to her it was the last time
she ever see them it was the last time
his wife would ever be with her ladies
and gentlemen as I walk to the room my
girl rather not Swami the author of the
popular book - journey home was right
next to him giving him both I was
astounded inside the little room there
were so many people I was standing right
next to him with my humor rather than
Swami I would say about 450 members of
her community
I want to either chanting the names of
God what I saw here was a man more than
a Lamborghini what I saw here was
support or a severe push people people
who were there to financially support em
people who are there to negative
supported people who were then to
spiritually supported people who have
been to emotionally supportive I was
amazed and the time to support this
manager you know something when you are
born people love you and when you die
people love in between your match
and this method managed to evil he
invested so much in relationships with
his people that the news and I mean
people had come to them
ladies and gentleman yes it is important
for us to have support well doesn't just
mean money well means money plus people
and support one gentleman said the
hoople's the difference between
completed and finished he said if you
find the right partner you're complete
so you find the long finish put it find
the icon catching you the homeowner
these fabulous with a new you need
friends with a dread we need
professional wrists
we definitely need people who get
supporters and therefore I say if you
want to talk truly how rich you are drop
a tear and see how many hands come forth
to wipe a tear that's how much you
actually
[Music]
now I've got a very special bonus clip
around choosing how you live your life
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but I'd love to know what did you think
about this video first what was your
impression what did you learn from this
don't just watch it in the video
but make a commitment to changing
something in your life what is that
change you're gonna make leave it in the
comments down below when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick so
put it down there thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
I was flying from Moscow Russia to Kiev
Ukraine I boarded the flight and the
stewardess came up to me and said
welcome onboard sir we guaranteed
takeoff I asked her landing madam she
said to me you're a monk aren't you pray
to the Oh Lord Almighty for a safe
landing we all are aware that when we
take a flight the takeoff is completely
beyond us we can do nothing about the
takeoff it's completely in the hands of
the pilot
[Music]
and when it comes to lending even the
landing is completely beyond our control
it's in the hand of the pilot many times
when I fly and there is a very smooth
landing where we don't even come to know
that the plane has landed people give an
ovation a loud round of applause I have
not been an exception either of course
the only thing is we don't give a
standing ovation because the seatbelt
sign is still on yes ladies and
gentlemen the landing is also beyond our
control and what about the turbulence
the turbulence during the journey during
the flight is also completely beyond us
the wind speed is beyond us when the
plane passes to the clouds and the
entire plane becomes wobbly it's not
enough control what is in our control
during the flight is our choice
some people choose to just go to sleep
yet others get completely drunk on
alcohol some watch movies some keep
munching something yet others make new
friends talk to others and network yes
what to do during that journey is in our
control in the journey of life as well
the take-off which is our birth is
completely beyond our control we didn't
choose our parents we didn't choose
which nation we vimana we didn't choose
which city paper bonnet we didn't choose
a socio-economic class beaver bonnet we
didn't choose our looks we didn't choose
the religion beaver bonnet our take off
of the journey of life was completely
beyond us and the landing death even
that could be completely beyond us I've
heard many times people telling me that
they would just love to die by getting a
massive heart attack and dropping dead
no trouble for them no hospitalization
no tubes no needles no trouble cost to
others in one shot go
now no matter how much we might wish
that it's just beyond us how we go and
how the landing happens is completely
beyond us and what about the turbulence
the disturbances the problems during the
journey of our life
some of them are within our control
which we can solve for many problems and
issues and the turbulence cost is
completely beyond our control because
it's caused by situations which are
beyond us it's caused by people who are
beyond us yes ladies and gentlemen in
this journey of life the takeoff the
landing and the turbulence is not enough
control what is in our control however
is the choices we can make
and therefore spirituality is about
learning how to make those right choices
when we learn to make those right
choices we learn to live a transformed
happy fulfilled life despite all the
turbulence and problems that are going
on around us
it is said when we are beautiful is
God's gift to us when we live our life
beautiful it is our gift to God
therefore being a meal is a matter of
birth being a man is a matter of age
being a gentleman is a matter of choice
and as a corollary to that being a
female is a matter of birth being a
woman is a matter of age being a
gentlewoman is a matter of choice
let us all take to spiritual wisdom
learn to make the right choices which
have predinner control as our gift to
God
and thus live our lives as thorough and
perfect
ladies and gentlemen raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people need passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details